congratulations
thank you
how was it to do two dances in just a
couple days
it it was hold on somebody's going here
i didn't think you guys bring you no
you're good sorry
it was insane it was stressful we've
never had to do two dances this early on
in the season and you could see the
stress that it put on not only the pros
but also the celebrities like that's a
lot to do i don't even think we start
introducing two dances until like week
seven it's week four
um so it was crazy
do you still think about that you're
making history this season or is it just
about the dancing now
you know i actually think yesterday was
a good good good reminder that we're
making history i think that we didn't
even put this together at the time but
yesterday was also national coming out
day
and i think doing the number where i was
prince charming and she was cinderella
a lot of people reached out to me and
said you have no idea what you're doing
for the community
you have no idea what you and jenna are
doing for little kids showing little
girls that they can be prince charming
and showing little boys that they can
wear dresses you can do anything you
want
it's it's who you are in your heart that
matters
oh that was such an aggressive knock
i wanted to actually touch on this
because i didn't really realize until i
met jojo we were talking about disney
night and i was like you know who's your
favorite disney princess and she told me
like
since i was young i never was into the
princesses i always wanted you know like
i just i never wanted to dress up as one
and i was like really never and then
have you ever seen any of the princess
movies yeah and then it hit me yesterday
you know when a lot of people were
reposting our number and they just said
you know not everyone sees themselves as
a princess but sometimes the prince and
it just hit me so clearly i think jojo
and i forgot that we were making history
and then this last night was a really
great reminder of that i feel like when
now
it's not we're two girls dancing
together we're making history it's like
we're best friends we're sisters we're
out there we're doing our little dancy
dance and then we're like oh wait yeah
this is pretty big
now i want to ask about the eliminations
tonight were you i mean because
were you even thinking that that it was
a possibility that you could go
yeah yeah the competition is so fierce
and
all of us were just so confused on who
was even gonna be in the bottom three
then the bottom two who was going and i
think every week is going to get even
more intense and like stressful because
it's a toss-up it really really is and
it's crazy to me that
i mean now only
three people have gone for four people
have gone home no only three only three
people have worked for you right four
people have gone home
and it's like
so
devastating i mean tonight after we
wrapped everyone was crying and
i felt like a loser for crying but then
i turned around and olivia's crying like
okay we can cry together like it's sad
you become a family with these people
yeah
oh
well next week greece
are you have you seen that film and are
you a fan or
i
this young has never seen it
i know but
i'm watching it tonight hey you never
saw descendants and you didn't do your
hair you didn't watch it you're right
i'm at least gonna do my homework grease
is though just like iconic it you so i'm
very i'm very excited for her to see it
because she knows all of the music from
it so i think she's going to appreciate
it even more when she sees it in the
scenes of her
you